we all die the question is
how many of us will run from it
[Music]
okay folks face the raven
what some people consider to be the
first part of a three-parter and if
you consider it that that means this is
act one of a story that falls completely
apart
in the third act at least to my memory i
am
still going forward trying to be
open-minded and i am really sorry that i
feel like i keep dwelling on where
things are going
with hell bent but a lot of stuff is
attempting to build towards it and some
of it even competently
that i can't help but have my mind on it
anyways so
this story starts
with the doctor and clara getting
contacted by rigsy because he has a
tattoo on the back of his neck that is
counting
down and he is understandably concerned
about this
so the doctor and clara try and help
they end up finding what they call a
trap
street it's hidden by basically a
souped-up perception filter
and they're a bunch of just sporadic
refugee aliens for lack of a better term
this is kind of interesting coming off
the back of the zygons knowing that they
were
integrated whereas these folks you know
seem to go out of their way to
self-isolate and this whole thing is
overseen
by lady me now mayor
me apparently or a shielder or you know
just maisie williams she's back
again so she's overseeing this whole
thing and there seems to be a very
tenuous law and order and amount of
control that she has over what goes on
here and ultimately a lot of that comes
down to
her employment of the raven
and what this is i forget what he what
the doctor calls it exactly but
it locks on to people with what's called
a chrono lock and when the timer counts
down
it comes for you it doesn't matter where
you run across time and space
it will find you and it will kill you
once it has been set up on you
and basically this means that
the way um a shielder
maintains order here is not
necessarily through an iron fist but
through a very
very harsh penal system
so they believe that rigzy
killed someone and he has now
had this timer set on him and is
counting down
now that might seem flimsy like he
appeared to be
there's no evidence there's no witnesses
there was no trial yes
that is correct there were none of those
things so
what we're dealing with here and this is
emitted openly by a shielder
which is good that she said this because
otherwise it would have seemed really
flimsy
which is her saying like they were angry
i had to do
something to quell the unrest
basically she had to offer up a
scapegoat and it really does
give us an idea of how uncertain and how
by a thread the piece in the street is
hanging on to
i wish that was a little bit more in
evidence in the interactions
because everybody seems pretty united
here
now granted they're united in an
apparent hatred of riggsy who they
otherwise know nothing about
but there doesn't we don't get a
tangible feel
of the tension between the residents
that we're
told exists so this is a case of telling
without showing properly as far as that
particular
element of the story goes but let's
start talking about the
big thing that happens here
clara does something that she thinks is
quite clever because at the beginning of
of this thing well not the beginning
beginning but once
they're all in this street a shielder
gives her reassurance to the doctor that
no harm will come to clara
so clara think once clara finds out that
the um the chronolog can be passed on
if um the person who has it is willing
to pass it and the person who's going to
receive it is willing to receive it
it can be moved from one person to
another and so she has rixie pass it on
to her because she thinks well
she gave her word that her won't come to
me so even if we fail at you know us
trying to prove your innocence
the you know no one will get hurt
because she won't let that happen
and it almost seems like a good idea but
obviously
clara is missing a few key details
and what we find out is
the raven once the lock has been set
needs to be satisfied and the only one
who can
break that contract is the person who
initially set it
on to the person so a shielder
can and at the end she is prepared to
remove the lock from rexy
the problem is once rigsy passes it onto
clara a shielder is no longer part of
the deal
it's been renegotiated without her and
she's been cut out
so now the only person who can remove
the lock
basically no longer has access to it
because it was part of a side deal
that she wasn't privy to and so now
clara's going to die
and they all know it and they can't stop
it
and she tries to face
that with bravery
and trying to be sure that
the doctor isn't going to go off the
rails
once she's gone and there's some other
stuff going on things
are honestly a little more complicated
than they need to be in terms of this
plot and it turns out the woman who was
dead isn't really dead
and it was all a scheme to get the
doctor in
just to get the doctor to like turn a
lock so that they could stick a
teleporter bracelet on him it's it's a
little overconvoluted
now it kind of gets away with it because
the emotional heart of it especially
once they realize clara is going to die
plays so strongly that it glosses over
and you know kind of
muscles you pass the fact that this
scheme was kind of absurd and ridiculous
because if you actually stop and think
about it it really was
like this was the most straightforward
way you could think to latch this thing
onto the doctor
really because this is convoluted as
hell
i mean like what what if rixie hadn't
had the doctor's number
or what if he did but he hadn't thought
to call them you know
there's some it's it's one of those
elaborate plans where like there's so
many things that you were dependent on
that you could not have been certain
would have happened the way that you
wanted them to like this is a bad plan
yeah it works but dang so
there's there's that element but like i
said it doesn't dwell on it which means
it doesn't allow the viewer to dwell on
it and to realize
it is a whole lot of nonsense
so that helps in terms of getting the
whole thing to
uh to move past what would otherwise be
a weak point because
that's not the point we have arrived at
the point the point is she's going to
die
and i've talked up to this point about
the things that this siri has
series has done in terms of laying
groundwork for
clara trying to be like the doctor of
her
having more fun than is probably safe
for her to be having
given the situations she is in this
actually isn't even a completely new
idea
series two did this a bit with rose and
the doctor now there
rose wasn't trying to be like the doctor
but their very flippant and carefree
attitude about stuff going on
was brought up by a number of characters
and in some ways
reflects the or helped uh enhance the
tragedy of when rose got
locked into the other dimension because
they were just so certain that
everything was going to work out okay
now what's interesting about this one
especially contrasting it with that is
not only is clara trying to be herself
much more like the doctor certainly than
rose ever was
but also the doctor isn't being flippant
but clara is and in my head that's
because the doctor remembers
how badly things went the last time
things got too comfortable and it felt
too easy
and so he's a little bit more nervous
and he said in previous episodes
don't try to be like me but clara
doesn't
know what has happened in the past
and she keeps trying
and this move that she pulls it's a very
doctor move or at least a doctor she
understands him
but because she doesn't have his
knowledge base
this decision kills her and it's even
set up within this episode because like
you have early on
like the very first scene they rush into
the tardis and they're talking about how
they almost got killed and she's
laughing they're trying to find the trap
street she is
looking out the door of the tardis with
the sonic sunglasses
and while they're flying over the city
and the tardis lurches
her entire top half falls out of the
tardis she is hanging there basically by
her
feet and laughing
she is so cocky and so certain that
she's gonna be okay
that she has become reckless
and she pays the price for it
that that that element of her
this series especially and like i
i will still say to a certain degree
that it feels like
they had different purposes and
character traits for clara that kind of
got bolted on
each series that went along but this
series they've decided
that what they were going to focus on
was her
arrogance her cockiness and it has
been appropriately planted and brought
into question as a potential character
flaw
and any good tragic end to a character
should be brought about by themselves to
a certain degree
not knowingly actually usually not
knowingly but it shouldn't somehow
in some way tied to a fatal character
flaw
and that is hers um at least hers as she
has presented in
this series but limiting my view
to series nine
this has been really well executed in
terms of building up to this
giving the hints to the audience that
you know maybe
the way she's going about being with the
doctor isn't the best and
having that be the end of her and
there's actually a quite a bit of power
when she does
as the title says face the raven
she tries to be strong
but once it enters her in the
in real time probably like a couple of
seconds
but it's done in slow motion so it's
drawn out
that the raven is inside her between
when that happens and when she dies she
screams and i think it was a very smart
idea
to not have that screen be audible
to the audience it is clearly audible as
characters around her react
and clearly hear it but we don't
because i think a scream would have
killed that moment and it plays much
stronger
having it be silent like this but
that it is clear she is making these
noises but we're just not going to hear
it
that moment plays very powerfully and
like i said
her talking to the doctor and saying
what she does to him to try and keep him
grounded to try and keep him from going
off the rails
i know what you're capable of
you don't be a warrior promise me
be a doctor she is pleading with him
to not succumb to the anger that she is
already seeing him feel
there's that wonderful moment from
capaldi when he yells at his shield or
a shield there's so certain like you
wouldn't you know he starts saying i'm
gonna bring
hell down on to this street if you don't
fix this
and she can't i know the doctor
the doctor the doctor is no longer here
you are stuck with me
so clara's already seeing
how angry he is just knowing he's about
to lose her
she knows how badly that this could go
and she's pleading with him
don't do that
which in some ways
is part of what really irritates me
about
hell bent when we get there or at least
has historically
again we'll see what i think when i
actually rewatch the thing
but for him to do what he does
in that episode is
to dishonor
cara he is
disregarding her last words to him her
pleas
to him and
one could make an argument that you know
there's nothing
wrong with a character you know
selfishly trying to bring someone back
the way that
i would say it does appear that he does
and the doctor does in hellbent
but for a character that had such a
wonderful sign off
and gave a very good argument for why
the doctor
should not be vengeful
it just feels wrong that ultimately he
will be
but that's something we'll deal with in
a couple of episodes
the the overall thing is fine
the i like the idea of the street the
execution of it is a bit more okay
having it be a shielder that that works
i'm not sure it really needed to be her
but i suppose to a certain degree
it did help that it was someone who the
doctor knew i guess theoretically it
could have been any character
the doctor had met before who was an
alien who would have a reason to be on
earth or you know just otherwise wasn't
just a straight human but
she's one we'd seen across the series
already so i guess she was an easy
enough go-to there's no reason
there's no there's nothing wrong with it
being her i'm just not sure
what it being her specifically adds to
the proceedings
but she's fine i still think the best
use of maisie williams was
in um the woman who lived but she's
still
solid here the um
it's the emotional beats in this and
it's the
it's the execution on clara's death
being brought about by her own
hubris that
works excellently and that's what needed
to work this is one of those episodes
where
it's not perfect but it absolutely
succeeds in the areas that it
had to any given story
there are some elements that if you
don't get this right the whole thing
falls apart but
if you nail that and there's weakness
elsewhere
it's it'll still be okay and that's kind
of the case here
the the plot to get the doctors kind of
nonsensical
there's a bit too much show don't tell
about the street itself as
as much as it's a a cool concept
but the things that absolutely had to
get right
it does so ultimately
this episode does succeed at what it
sets out to do
and it's a strong setup for what is
about to come immediately after
and then for what comes after that
oh we're getting close to this thing i'm
so nervous
i'm actually nervous even for the next
one because i love heaven scent
i really really do and i have not
rewatched it in a bit
but we'll see face the raven
have you re-watched it lately what do
you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it
i have a patreon which helps keep the
lights on and
keeps my bills covered and there are
various rewards you get access to videos
early
you get to vote in polls you get to see
my docket for the month so you get to
see what i have coming up
plus there's a discord and a bunch of
other stuff and even if you're not able
to do that liking sharing subscribing
all those things
do help me out as well but
you also don't have to end of the day
you're the council i'm just running the
meeting and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye